>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Tom Gjelten: I know that Susan
was signing books before the event
so, I'm sure that some of you have
already met her but for those of you
who have not, Susan Jacoby
is a historian and scholar
who specializes in the history of
atheism and secularism and freedom
of religion or more precisely,
I think we could say,
freedom from religion.
She is a board member of the
Freedom from Religion Foundation
and she's an independent
scholar which I find fascinating.
You're not affiliated
with the University?
>> Susan Jacoby: No.
>> Tom Gjelten: And
you don't have a PhD?
>> Susan Jacoby: No.
>> Tom Gjelten: So, what that
means to me, as a journalist
as I have great respect from
people who tackle these complex,
historical subjects without an
institutional support behind them
or advanced study in libraries
because inevitably I think
those books turn out a lot
of esoteric knowledge and esoteric
references that are often written
to impress other academics.
I can tell you that Susan
Jacoby's writing is,
I would guess because you
are an independent scholar,
very accessible, beautifully
written,
very friendly to a
broad public audience.
Susan is the author of several
books including "Free Thinkers,
A History of American Secularism",
" The Age of American Unreason",
"The Great Agnostic: Robert
Ingersoll and American Freethought"
and "Half-Jew: A Daughter's Search
for Her Family's Buried Past".
And that's a story which is
highly relevant to her latest book
which we're going to be
discussing today, "Strange Gods,
A Secular History of Conversion".
So Susan it's a real
pleasure to meet you
and have this opportunity
to talk to you.
>> Susan Jacoby: Likewise.
>> Tom Gjelten: I want everyone
to look at this, this is my copy
of the book and you know
sometimes interviews, I haven't--
I'll let you in a secret.
Sometimes interviews don't really
read a book very thoroughly before
they interview the
author, you can see.
>> Susan Jacoby: No.
>> Tom Gjelten: You can see
that I actually did read this
and it's covered with
post nits-- post notes.
It's a fascinating book, I
love this book very much.
It's really much more than
a history of conversion.
To me, Susan, it seems
like it's really a history
of intellectual thought
over the past 2000 years,
it's a secular account of the
history of religion in many ways
but you have focused it in this
unusual way by looking specifically
at religious conversions.
So what is it that the study
of conversions tells us?
>> Susan Jacoby: Well it tells
first of all that what we all know
from all sorts of things
that are going on today.
The religious conversion
is a big driver of history,
that whether you're talking
about the triumph of Christianity
over Paganism in the declining
Roman Empire or for that matter,
I should say this book is almost
entirely about Western History
because otherwise, it would have
been a thousand pages long instead
of 600 pages long.
>> Tom Gjelten: And would it take
any more than six years to write?
>> Susan Jacoby: Yeah
and there are--
and I would say that that book
would be best done by someone
with a strong Hindu or
Buddhist background.
But, it's a big driver of
history and is always mixed
up with political changes and
other kinds of social changes.
For example, I don't think that
Christianity, I think Christianity
in the decline of the Roman
Empire and I don't mean,
I don't share Gibbon's
view that the decline
of the Roman Empire was caused
by Christianity but the rise
of new religions to
provide something
that Pagan Roman society
wasn't providing
for people, was very well into that.
There were lots of conversions
to Judaism as I point
out in the declining Roman Empire
too and initially of course,
Romans regarded Christianity as
just another form of Judaism but so,
Christianity obviously, the
change from Catholic Europe
to Christian Europe that included
Protestantism, the reformation.
Again, another huge
change of, you know,
thing about religion
is a driver of history.
>> Tom Gjelten: These are really
turning points, which this year--
>> Susan Jacoby: These
are turning points.
The-- at the intersection
of religion politics, look,
you can certainly say that without
the reformation, it's quite possible
that the United States would
not have been settled in the way
that it was at all and I don't
mean just by puritans I mean
by people whom the puritans were
persecuting back home who didn't--
but the puritans didn't get to do it
here because people just moved away
from Massachusetts to New
York and Pennsylvania.
So that's one of the reasons I'm
really interested in conversion
and then my family background
makes me particularly interested
and I see some people whom I know
have read some of my earlier books.
I was brought up a Catholic and I
didn't find out until I was about 17
that my father was born a Jew and
he was a convert to Catholicism.
Now, I would have found this
out much sooner, had I not grown
up in a small town where
there were almost no Jews.
If I'd lived in New York, I would
have realize that Jacoby if you go
for a back enough is
always a Jewish name.
But I didn't.
And my grandmother when she
married my grandfather was a convert
from Lutheranism to
Catholicism, you know,
to please my grandfather's family.
Can I tell my little story, do
I have time about everyone then,
this is 1919, I mean, nobody
thinks that much of a conversion
like that today but in 1919
it was something and they went
to the priest to take instruction as
they called it before their marriage
and he asked out right if my
grandmother was or the family way.
And my grandfather reared up
and he said, she's as innocent
as the Virgin Mary, no thanks to me.
All I've done is kiss her and you
have a dirty mind and he wanted
to go to a judge to get married
but my grandmother wouldn't let him
because she thought his
mother would be very upset.
So apparently, they went as my
grandmother told me the story
and I found him more sympathetic
priest with a less dirty mind.
>> Tom Gjelten: So your father
converted but and then his uncles
who obviously were Jewish as
well also converted correct?
>> Susan Jacoby: No, that was my
father's brother who converted.
My Uncle Lassie [assumed spelling]
who was a famous Bridge
Champion also converted.
He converted a little later in
his life than my father did.
He broke his back he's had as--
my uncle Lassie who was alive
when I was writing my memoir
Half-Jew told me, he said, you know,
my Catholic wife pounced and you
know, she thought I was dying
and so she got me to
agree to being baptized.
>> Tom Gjelten: So, how do
you explain those conversions?
In other words, in what category
would you put those conversions
in your family?
>> Susan Jacoby: I would put them
in the category, two categories.
One in the category,
the biggest driver
of conversion throughout
history has been intermarriage.
And by that, I emphasized, I don't
mean that I consider those put
on conversions or false conversions.
When people fall in love with
someone of another faith,
often they become interested
in that religion.
It's part of this,
you become interested
in what books another person
reads or something like that.
But in the case of my father's
family, they were also,
they were family, they were
a family of German Jews
and like many German Jews, they were
very secular in the 19th century
and I do know that my
father's father was very--
there was a lot of shame
around being Jewish.
And I think that-- I don't
think it's an accident
when all three siblings
in the family,
all marry Irish Catholics
and convert.
Although they didn't really know
anything about Judaism either.
So I think there was both falling in
love with someone of another faith,
very common motivation
but also in the case
of my father's family's
attitude toward Judaism.
My dad told me, I did ask my
father about this and he said that,
this is how he regarded being a Jew.
He said, I didn't want you
and your brother ever to think
that if you didn't get
something you wanted in life,
it was because you were Jewish.
Isn't-- that's one
of the saddest things
that my father ever said to me.
So it's a combination of both.
But my father was also a compulsive
gambler and again, this is involved
in many conversions and it's both
spiritual and non-spiritual in way.
My father felt that the
rituals are religion
and why not become a Catholic,
your married with Catholic,
you have children being
raised as Catholics.
The rituals of religion would
help him overcome gambling just
as George W. Bush felt that the
religion he adopted would help him
overcome alcoholism.
And that too, is a mixed kind
of motive, so if you're asking,
does this have anything to do with
forced conversion in the sense
of people doing it
because they're going
to have their property
taken away or be killed?
>> Tom Gjelten: Which has happened?
>> Susan Jacoby: No.
Which is also another
kind of conversion.
But I would say it was a combination
of mixed marriage and
social opportunism.
>> Tom Gjelten: Those are very
practical motivations right there.
>> Susan Jacoby: Yes.
>> Tom Gjelten: Now, you know,
I think when a lot of us think
of religious conversion,
we think the sort
of the prototypical conversion
as the one you have
depicted for this is a--
>> Susan Jacoby: No.
Caravaggio depicted it.
>> Tom Gjelten: That's right.
>> Susan Jacoby: I wish.
>> Tom Gjelten: Right but it's the--
it's Saul of Tarsus who is on
his way on the road to Damascus
and he sees a light and
he becomes convinced
that Jesus Christ has spoken
to him and from that moment
on he becomes Paul and the most--
that's the most famous
conversion of all.
Now you-- in this painting, he's
depicted as falling off a horse,
which I don't think is in
the bible, actually that's.
>> Susan Jacoby: No.
>> Tom Gjelten: So
you must have seen--
>> Susan Jacoby: Because
he had a blow,
it's that he had a blow on the head.
It is however, at-- as if
he's been depicted by artist
and the bible does say
he woke up on the ground.
So that would imply a fault.
And what else would he have
been going to the Damascus to--
there are only three
ways to get from Damascus
to Jerusalem and vice versa.
One is on foot, which I don't he
was because he was going to fair it
out Christians in Damascus
to report them back
to the high priest in Jerusalem.
>> Tom Gjelten: And whether he fell
off of a horse or was struck by,
you know, something that more
inspiring than a blow in the head,
still, we think of this
as being a conversion,
a true spiritual conversion that
he was spoken to by God or Christ
and as a result of that
experience, he became a Christian.
But, so that would clearly
would not be in the category
of an opportunistic or a prophet--
>> Susan Jacoby: He became
a follower of the way.
Nobody used the word Christian.
>> Tom Gjelten: OK, all right.
But you say in your book
that it's only a tiny slice
of converts throughout
Western history
who have converted
for emotional reasons.
So, you should defend that statement
because that's quite
a sweeping statement.
>> Susan Jacoby: Well,
I should have said,
I should have said
purely spiritual reasons.
>> Tom Gjelten: OK.
>> Susan Jacoby: And I meant that
for purely spiritual reasons,
I don't mean in my view, the
spiritual or the emotional
and I'm using them
interchangeably and I think they are
because when you read just
there are many other conversions
like Saul's throughout history and
when you read about at it's always
as a highly emotional
overnight experience.
But I don't think since
conversion when you're talking
about large numbers of
conversions, they tend to occur
at great times of social upheaval.
They tend to occur in societies
which the late Roman Empire was
that were except during
certain epics, you know,
we've heard about Nero's
persecution and Diocletian's.
But they tend to occur and I think
that's one reason America has
so much conversion.
They tend to occur in societies
where it's possible even
though it may become impossible
and they may be persecuted
eventually so,
I defend that statement by saying
that what I said was
purely spiritual.
I don't say that spiritual
motivation is an important.
I think as I said, I
think for my father,
the desire to overcome
a personal fault,
I would call it a spiritual
motivation, but as far as people
in general, no, do I think
that Ivanka Trump for instance
who converted because she married
a Jew, fell in love with him?
Do I think that Ivanka woke
up one morning and said oh,
I've been wrong all these
years, Jesus isn't the Messiah,
I really believe in Judaism.
No, she fell in love with and
maybe undoubtedly become genuinely
interested in Judaism, so
I don't think that the--
I would defend my statement
by saying that I don't think
that it's impossible or even
unlikely to have both spiritual
and non-spiritual motives.
>> Tom Gjelten: We'll get
back to some individual cases
but as I said before, one of the
things I found most fascinating
about your book is that by
talking about conversions,
you really illuminate history and
you illuminate these turning points
of history in these
great changes in history.
Talk a little bit about the
growth of early Christendom
in the declining Roman Empire
and sort of the triumph
over Paganism and how that happened?
How those great, that
great wave of conversion
which was really the
first big conversion
that you write about in your book?
>> Susan Jacoby: Right.
Well, first of all, it didn't
happen, it didn't happen overnight.
There were lots of religions
competing with Paganism
in the late Roman Empire.
Judaism is one of them,
people don't realize
that because Judaism is an
active proselytizing religion
and Manicheism which Augustine of
Hippo was originally attracted to,
was another one and certainly things
could have turned out differently
and it could have run out
instead of Christianity.
But once it happened in the late
Roman Empire was a lot of Romans,
particularly well off
Romans were disgusted
by the decadence of Roman society.
And both Judaism and Christianity,
that's why ascetic
movements too were
which Christianity
wasn't nearly as extreme
in as certain forms
of Manicheism were.
So they were attracted
to something that seemed
to offer a purpose
and an explanation.
And then at the same time, in the
fourth century which is really
when Christianity begins to triumph,
early fifth century, Vandals
and the Goths overrun Rome.
And a lot of wealthy Romans
become refugees in North Africa.
They brought with them
their money to the church
and money was very important in
that they attracted Christianity
with not only the religion
of the poor but it was also,
it became the religion of choice
ultimately certainly the emperors,
Constantine and Theodosius.
When your emperor picks
Christianity,
that also encourages
the upper classes.
Again, it's a mixture of things.
Notice, I'm talking about
attraction to a religion that seemed
to offer more spiritually than
Paganism, but at the same time,
you're talking about a religion
that your emperor was speaking.
Constantine opened up to
civil service to Christians.
You didn't have to-- after
Constantine, you didn't have to give
up your job in the
Roman civil service
if you wanted to become a Christian.
So I think this thing is--
>> Tom Gjelten: So it became
at a certain point then it
became advantageous to--
>> Susan Jacoby: At certain points,
in parts of the Roman Empire,
it became advantageous and certainly
by the early fifth century,
mid fifth century, it was
settled, Christianity won out,
Manicheism lost out and then you'd
begin to have anti-Semitism of level
that had not existed in
the Roman Empire before.
>> Tom Gjelten: And once
Christianity had established this
foothold, not only in Europe,
but as you say, in North Africa,
it actually took on a more
aggressive form you write about.
And actually, Christians
themselves having been persecuted
in the early stages of Christendom
became persecutors, you say?
>> Susan Jacoby: Yes
and also different sects
within Christianity became
persecutors of each other too.
Arguing over, over whether the
Roman church was going to survive
or whether the forms which were more
native to North Africa and you know,
that of course the East or
West split in Christianity,
Catholicism continues to this day.
But the thing that happened in the
Roman Empire, it was not unusual.
It's once the church in
the state got together,
what situation has there
ever been in history?
When the church has, had at its
disposal, the power of the state
to enforce its belief and
by the church, I just mean,
churches just as in John Calvin's
Geneva became a theocracy,
every bit as bad as theocratics,
Spain and Portugal
during the inquisition.
There is no incidence in
history of a theocracy
which is practice religious
tolerance and freedom of religion.
Forget freedom from religion
which is freedom from religion,
freedom of religion
are integrally linked.
They had-- they have to be.
There has been no theocratic
society which has ever been tolerant
of other religions, it wouldn't by
definition be a theocratic society.
>> Tom Gjelten: Now, the--
you mentioned the inquisition
and of course, that is kind
of the prototypical period
where Christians persecuted
Jews and Muslims and for that,
you talked about the expulsion
when Jews and Muslims were expelled
from the Iberian Peninsula
that unless they converted
to Christianity.
But prior to the inquisition,
there was this period
that's called La Convivencia
where you actually
had Islam, Judaism
and Christianity coexisting
relatively peacefully,
what happened?
>> Susan Jacoby: Well, what
happen was the Reconquista.
When the Christians retook
all of Spain, they then,
the Muslim rulers were
tolerant of the right of Jews.
They called themselves
people of the book.
They weren't tolerant
of Pagans however.
But they were, the three
Monotheistic religions pretty much
coexisted and we know, here is my
intermarriage, not theory I think.
Theory in the sense of
Einstein, theory of relativity,
but we know there was a lot of
intermarriage during La Convivencia.
How do we know this?
Because there was a massive
DNA study done of people
on the Iberian Peninsula.
It was completed about 10 years ago.
Found out that 20% of all residents
of Spain today possess Sephardic
Jewish genes due to DNA analysis
and almost 15 percent possess
North African Muslim genes.
Now obviously, this means there
was a lot fully around right
from the start, whatever
people thought about it.
And as happens, when the people
of different religions have a
fair amount of political equality
which they did, Jews and
Christians weren't quite equal
under Muslim rulers, but
they were fairly equal.
They were persecuted
for their religion.
>> Tom Gjelten: But you had
this period of coexistence
which is sadly not very common
throughout Western history.
Whom do you credit for that?
Do you credit-- it sounds
like you'll credit the--
there were Muslim rulers
but there was also,
there were also Christian
monarchs, Alfonso X was--
>> Susan Jacoby: Yes.
There were Christian monarchs
who didn't share Ferdinand
and Isabella's views.
They weren't like, they did
business and not only that,
but during La Convivencia in Spain,
this is the dark ages
in Northern Europe.
But in La Convivencia, the
Arabs had translated many
of the Greek classics which
were lost in Northern Europe
at that time except in monasteries.
They weren't available to an
educated person who was interested
in the classical heritage.
Well this data have been translated
into Arabic by the Arabs and contact
between Jews, Christians and Muslims
in La Convivencia in Spain was
such that then got
retranslated back into Latin.
And that--
>> Tom Gjelten: Thanks to the Arabs.
>> Susan Jacoby: Thanks to
the Arabs, thanks to the fact
that there was-- and eventually a
retranslated, a few centuries later
into their merging
vernaculars of Europe.
>> Tom Gjelten: Yeah.
Well that's, it's an important thing
to remember now because you know,
there is so much animosity
between Islam and Christianity
that there was this period
where it was the Muslims
who are the most civilized and
enlightened in that part of Europe,
it sounds like what you're saying.
>> Susan Jacoby: At
that point in Europe?
Yes.
>> Tom Gjelten: Yeah, yeah.
Now, and then we get to
the Protestant Reformation,
another one of these
great turning point
that is itself a story
of conversions.
And you write the-- the spread of
vernacular bibles, the translation
of the bible into German,
another vernacular languages
allowed every literate person,
direct access to the scriptures
without mediation of priests
and of course, Martin Luther
was instrumental in that he was,
he translated the New
Testament into German himself
and he was obviously a big
advocate of bypassing priests,
encouraging direct contact
communication with God.
And you write between roughly
1517 and 1550 huge numbers
of Europeans changed their minds
about what constituted the
foundation of their lives,
encompassing their view of the
universe, of relations between God
and man, and of the proper way
for individual human
beings to seek truth.
So talk a little bit about that
because that, on the one hand,
that is obviously politically
very important but it sounds
like it had a lot of
spiritual significance as well
because it really changed
the way people as you say,
saw their relation to
God, that's a pretty--
>> Susan Jacoby: They saw--
>> Tom Gjelten: --
spiritual development.
>> Susan Jacoby: -- their
relation to God as one thing,
a more direct relationship with God
which is again a religious
issue that's still
with us in America today.
Protestantism, because it encouraged
reading in the vernacular,
involved a more direct
relationship to God.
But of course, it didn't
take very long,
less than 100 years before
there became new kinds
of Protestants whom the first
Protestant reformers, the Lutherans,
and the Calvinist didn't like.
And they were the Nonconformist
Protestants, the Baptists,
the Quakers, the Anabaptists,
the Huguenots.
Many of whom, our own
founders were descended on--
descended from which I didn't
know until I wrote Freethinkers,
that a lot of our founders, their
grandparents were Huguenot refugees
from France, where not only, there
was not only the Catholic church
that objected to Huguenots
under Louis XIV
but the Magisterial Protestants
as they're called, the first ones.
The Lutherans and the
Calvinists, they also objected
to Nonconformist Protestants
to like,
Quakers were persecuted in England.
That's how a lot of them wound
up with founding Pennsylvania.
>> Tom Gjelten: But let's
stick for a moment on that,
the early period of the reformation.
Those people who became Protestants,
who converted from Catholicism
to Protestantism as a result of
the translation of the bible,
would you consider those
to be spiritual conversions
or opportunistic conversions?
>> Susan Jacoby: I would say,
except for the very first ones,
mostly both, spiritual in
the sense that the chance
to read these things for-- and also
probably the vernacular translations
encourage people to read who--
more people to learn to read
who wouldn't have otherwise.
We know that the rate
of literacy in Europe
and Protestant countries was higher
than in Catholic countries
at that time.
But I would say both.
There's always a tipping point
once your ruler adopts religion,
when something becomes both
pragmatically desirable
as well as spiritual.
But I would say both.
But the first Magisterial
Protestants, I mean,
Calvin's Geneva was a pit of horror,
with basically secret police,
monitoring every home,
having exactly
like Stalin's communist party,
having rules that governed every
aspect of life, can't have more
than 16 people over for dinner.
There was no reason for that except
they just were so opposed to fun
of every kind, that maybe they
thought too much fun was being had
if there were more
than 16 people there.
>> Tom Gjelten: And as you say,
it was precisely at that moment
of religious persecution in
Europe among these rival sects
that the United States was founded
and you make it a very
interesting connection
between our tradition
of religious liberty.
And the birth of the United States
under enlightenment influences
with what was going on
in Europe at that time?
>> Susan Jacoby: Well look, when you
think, think jump ahead a little bit
from the 17th century where
our first colonists arrived
and as we know, the Massachusetts
Bay colony was not religiously
tolerant at all.
The difference between America
and Europe was that people
who descended, they didn't
get killed there necessarily.
They got, they left for New York
and the Salem witch trials happened
at the point where the Massachusetts
Theocracy was breaking down,
that's my friend Stacey Schiff
has written and that's very true.
But the founders, when they
write the constitution,
it's less than a 100 years
after Protestants and Catholics,
and Protestants and Protestants
were murdering each other in Europe
over such earth shaking issues
as, is it OK to baptize babies
or you do need to wait
for adult baptism?
This was one of the major sources
of many religious wars in Europe.
And when you think
about the founders,
all having a state religion meant
to them was the kind of trouble,
they were all educated men,
all of them were educated.
Probably the most educated group
of people founding a country
wherever existed, what--
having a state religion meant
to them was the mess
that was in Europe.
And so that's why they wrote
the constitution first of all,
prohibiting any religious
test for public offers.
And the First Amendment
the way they did.
They saw absolutely no value
in having a state religion
and a lot that was wrong.
I mean, one of the most
exciting things you know,
reading from before the revolution,
1767, the end of the French
and Indian war in New York.
They have big celebration
to commemorate the victory,
the British victory
at French in the war.
All of the churches and the only
synagogue in Manhattan were allowed
to participate in this
and read their sermons
of thanksgiving and so on.
Now, this would have been
absolutely unthinkable in Europe,
that a synagogue would
have been included in this.
So that the seeds that came to
fruition in the constitution
so shortly afterwards were
already there in colonial America.
>> Tom Gjelten: OK, I've
taken enough of Susan's time.
It's your turn now to--
we didn't really get
into 20th century America which--
>> Susan Jacoby: Not at all.
>> Tom Gjelten: Which is
another whole great story
of conversions in the United States.
But anyone have any
questions for Susan Jacoby?
Yeah, there are sorry, yes?
There are two mics.
One in each aisle, here, if you
would be so kind so we can hear you
and everybody can hear you.
>> Hi. Thank you, that was
fascinating and I feel like I want
to replay the video and
absorb it some more.
You bring this extraordinary sense
of how religion affects
geopolitics and frankly, war.
How-- if you, a bit
wishful thinking,
but if you could wave a magic wand
or whatever or counsel the UN,
how would you address the
Middle East crisis and these--
no but seriously because
these are religious wars.
These are ultimately religious wars.
That's really what
they boil down to.
Arabs versus Jews, et cetera and
how would you counsel them just
to structure some of these
deals to address the tolerance
of the given religions in a
way that can be a resolution?
>> Susan Jacoby: I can't
believe you asked me that.
But I'm just going
to answer honestly
and not try and give you nonsense.
I do not think that the situation
in the Middle East is
anything but containable.
The advice I would give
anyone who was in charge
of our country was just as you
couldn't quote when the cold war,
something, an idea I hate.
There is no way with a certain
proportion of people in that region
of the world whose minds are
stuck in the eight century
and certain proportion of people in
Israel whose minds are still stuck
in 18th century Poland and
Russia, but the difference is
that Israel isn't' going out.
And well Israel is a
whole other question.
But I don't think that the situation
in the Middle East is anything
but containable, like in the
sense of preventing people
from murdering their neighbors,
which obviously we haven't
succeeded in doing either.
And I don't think it will be
anything but containable as long
as there is this segment of Islam.
Both the terrorist and
Theocratic states like Saudi Arabia
who by the way not only persecute
Christians and not only hate Jews
but persecute free thinkers who
blog about things like freedom
of religion and other
Muslims who don't agree
with their view of Islam, also.
So I don't have an answer for that.
I don't feel optimistic.
>> Tom Gjelten: You sir?
>> I just have a quick
question on your feelings
about our government's protection
of apostates on different groups.
>> Susan Jacoby: I'm sorry.
>> Tom Gjelten: Apostates.
Could you just clarify--
when you say
of different groups,
you mean, overseas?
>> All of the various ones,
I mean, Muslims usually are
on everybody's minds but
I'm thinking also of Mormons
and Scientologists and the
terrible things they do
to the people that wished to leave.
>> Susan Jacoby: You mean, wished to
leave their sects, their religions?
I don't-- I don't see that our
government protects Mormons.
Mormons place like many religions
like Hasidic Jews for example also.
Any one and I've done a lot
of interviewing of people
who have left the kinds of
religious sects that try
to control every aspect
of daily life,
which not all Mormons are like.
But I don't see that our
government protects them.
>> Tom Gjelten: Because one
thing if they should do more
to protect people who want to leave.
>> Susan Jacoby: Well,
I don't first of all,
I know a lot of people
who have left.
I'm only speaking now of America.
I know a lot of people who
have left the Mormon Church.
They used to come to our
center for inquiry meetings.
I know a lot of people
who have left,
Satmar and Lubab, your
Hasidic Judaism.
And there was tremendous
social pressure placed on them,
but I don't know what
our government could do
to make you exercise
freedom of conscience.
It's very painful, some of the most
painful interviews I have ever had,
have been with these
people and what they went
through because they were not
just leaving their religion.
They were in most cases,
leaving their families
and the only world
they've ever known.
But I don't think there's
anything government could do.
The government has done one thing
it can do our government has never
for example honored as many,
many ultra-Orthodox Jews try
to prevent women from
getting a divorce,
by not giving them a
gift, a religious divorce.
Our courts have always said
that religious divorce,
laws governing religious marriage
and religious laws have no
civil standing in other words,
your divorce according to the
laws of whatever state you live
in whether your husband
gives you a get or not.
But what our government
could do, much less should do
about giving a woman the
courage to forsake a religion,
it says only a man
can grant a divorce.
I don't really see what
our government could do.
One thing I think that it should
do is I think we should be much
tougher, have many fewer
religious exemptions
for things regarding medical
procedures and vaccination.
And we've-- This is still a
problem even though it's not as bad
as it was only 10 years
ago because custody,
medical custody can be
taken away from parents
who deny lifesaving standard
medical care to their children.
But that's the only place I think
that the government
could effectively act.
>> Tom Gjelten: Let
me ask you a question
since there's nobody
at the mic right now.
You write, you do not consider any
form of secular thought a religion,
unless the secular
ideology possesses a civil
enforcement mechanism.
I'm sure you know there's been
a big debate in this country
around separation of church
and state that in fact,
secularism does have
the status of a religion
and when the United States
forbids for example, bible,
when the US government forbids
bible reading in schools,
it's actually enforcing secularism
to the disadvantage
of other religions.
This was an argument
that Potter Stewart made
in the 1960's in the Supreme Court.
>> Susan Jacoby: Yes and I
think it's a wrong argument
because the purpose of
public schools is not
to teach or foster religion.
Not to say that when America was
an entirely Protestant country,
it wasn't taking very for granted
to study let's say the bible
or to recite prayers,
Christian prayers originating
or to recite prayers to God that
affects all children who are not
of the majority religion.
And I'll say something
else also and this is for,
not everybody here is an
atheist or an Agnostic.
I think a lot of this idea that the
government is enforcing secularism,
by not allowing religion
in that kind
of a public space is
particularly important.
It's in a way, a confession on
the part of some religious people
of the ineffectiveness of religion,
because if there is anything it
seems to me, it's an obligation
of a parent to do, it is to try
and pass on what you believe
as I don't have children,
but if I did, I certainly,
I don't for example
understand how someone I know,
I know for example an atheist who
is married to a devout Catholic.
And they both tell their children
what they think and I can understand
that because to me, a person's
religious beliefs are deeply
important and while I have lots of
friends who are observant Catholics
and Jews and Protestants, I would
find it impossible to raise a child
to believe for example in the
virgin birth and all of that.
>> Tom Gjelten: Or to make
up his or her own mind.
>> Susan Jacoby: Or to,
or children can make up,
can make up their own minds.
They will eventually, whatever you
do, but I would not want to see,
I-- my child in any case.
I think it is the function of
the church and the family to pass
on their religious beliefs
to the next generation.
It is not the function of a
public school and I don't think
that makes secularism a
religion, because not studying,
say the Christian or the Hebrew
bible or the Koran is not saying
that those things aren't good.
It is saying that we don't
teach this in school.
I don't teach for exam-- but
what else isn't taught in school?
It's the function of the home.
To some extent, in school, you may
teach people about sexual anatomy,
but you may not tell
him whether you should
or you shouldn't use birth control.
That's not anything I
think that is the function
of a school unless
it's a medical clinic
for teenagers who come and ask.
>> Tom Gjelten: Well that's a hot
button topic subject [inaudible].
>> Susan Jacoby: No, but
it's related to religion.
>> Tom Gjelten: Right, yeah.
Sir, we have just a few minutes
left so-- we have two minutes left.
>> In recent times, there's
very really dramatic decrease
in the adherence to Christianity
in Europe, I'm just curious
about your respective
on the reasons for that.
>> Susan Jacoby: Well,
I think actually--
there's been actually a fairly
dramatic decrease in America too.
It doesn't mean they're not
religious but 25% of Americans,
almost 25% now say that religion
no longer plays an improtant role
in their daily lives so that they--
they're not, it doesn't
mean they're atheists again.
And that they're not
members of any church.
I think this process is
far more advanced in Europe
because of Europe's history
of religious persecution
and separation of church and state.
Europeans who leave their
default church, so Catholicism
in Southern Europe,
Protestantism in Northern Europe,
tend to go straight to secularism.
In other words, you don't get very
many, many Lutherans in Germany--
in the Lutheran part of Germany
converting to Catholicism.
You don't get very many Catholics
in Italy converting to Judaism
or wichenism [assumed
spelling] or Islam or whatever.
They go straight to secularism
but that's because I think
that if you come from a country with
a history of religious persecution,
you tend not to be as
eager as Americans are
to substitute one religion
for another.
I mean, look at Europeans, Americans
often, they're mixed couples
who choose a third religion like
Senator Harry Reid and his wife
who was an Orthodox Jewish family.
He was raised a Protestant,
they decided to choose Mormonism
as the third way when
they got married.
Now, I think frankly this did
have something to do with the fact
that there's a large
Mormon vote in Nevada
and Harry Reid was
a funny politician.
But even if there weren't politics
involved, that would seem insane
to most of the Europeans I know,
whatever their religion is,
so you just go out and pluck
a third religion, you know,
out of the air, you know?
>> Tom Gjelten: Well listen,
we've only scratched the
surface of this subject.
>> Susan Jacoby: This is the
best interview, I've ever had.
>> Tom Gjelten: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
But there's so much more-- there
is so much more in this book.
It's really a fascinating book.
It covers so much territories, this
then took many years to write it.
So thank you so much, it's
been great, thanks for coming.
Thank you Susan Jacoby.
>> Susan Jacoby: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.